welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and this is a breakdown of the
trailer for Aquaman and the lost kingdom
coming December 20th the last we think
of the DC slate before the Gods and
Monsters reset following up the 2018
Aquaman which is insanely the highest
grossing DC film ever worldwide with
1.148 billion compared to the Dark
Knight Rises 1.081 billion but just some
context Christmas 2018 moviegoers had no
other major franchise movie to drag
their families to during the holidays
and paid off then and could it pay off
again I mean James Wan is totally
cooking up some jaw-dropping visuals for
this sequel so I'm gonna break down this
shot by shot for some details you might
have missed and how this film could be
the most controversial film of 2023.
okay we open with the Warner in DC logos
stamped into icebergs surely not helping
with their rapid melting but that might
actually be part of what's going on in
this movie we hear the voice of Aquaman
Arthur Curry Jason Momoa reminding us of
his status four years prior even though
that movie was five years ago this movie
was supposed to come out in 2022 so it's
gonna be four years but back then he was
an employed homeless Wanderer and he
leads with the word unemployed which I
just find to be a very interesting part
of this trailer Arthur describes his
divine right of King as a job not a
responsibility not a civic duty but like
a gig that one would get like a paycheck
for I finally got a job I'm the king of
Atlantis yeah well I hate this job being
a king is not a job my friend but it's
interesting that he describes it this
way because it implies it's something
that he could quit it just kind of feels
like to me that he's not going to end
this movie remaining on the throne of
Atlantis I think it's actually going to
be a Redemption story for orm as he
reclaims his status as he comes back
into the light with a new Fresh
perspective now this shot of Arthur on
the shore is actually shot from the 2018
film when Arthur makes its way to the
dead Kings Island in the realm of the
Hidden sea reunites with his mother
Atlanta on break from her visits to AMC
and acquires the Trident of atlan so you
know In that clip that everyone's making
fun of for the 2018 film Willem Dafoe
volko was not stifling a laugh he was
just hiding the truth that Atlanta was
not executed she was just banished are
you saying they executed her
because she had me
yup we see Arthur picnicking by the
curry family Lighthouse Jason Momoa
doing what looks like some Maori Warrior
poses which were Morrison Arthur has a
baby now and Amber Heard is definitely
in this trailer see she she's right here
kind of like Marla Hoods from The
Outfield what a hitter what a hitter oh
my God what a hitter I am not implying
anything about Amber heard's legal
history with Johnny Depp by saying Marla
Hooch would have hit her it's reference
to A League of Their Own that's it
that's it I swear now some very
important Comics context that we all
need to know here Arthur Curry Jr the
baby becomes Aqua baby with similar
Powers as Aquaman and a trigger warning
here in the comics Black Manta does
kidnap Aqua baby puts the baby in his
fear fills his fear with air so Aqua
baby can't really breathe it makes
Aquaman fight Aqualad to save Aqua baby
and then after the fight Arthur
discovers that Aqua baby is dead I know
I know would this movie ever actually do
that to this sweet sweet cherub I would
think not but Black Manta does say a
throughout this trailer I'm gonna kill
Aquaman and destroy everything he holds
dear I'm gonna murder his family and
then later we hear he means to end the
bloodline end the bloodline now yes
historically many royal power struggles
have resulted in infanticide something
that the Song Of Ice And Fire series
that Jason Momo is also part of is no
stranger to but you know what folks this
is going to be a Christmas movie you
know when Jesus was born so I would hope
for nothing scarier than you know some
like Jack Jack syndrome stuff then again
there were some unconfirmed reports of
test screenings for this movie going
really poorly and people walking out and
for a lot of audiences off eat a baby is
a lie needle cross my guess is that
they're just going to kill Thomas or
Mira instead so we see Arthur and Thomas
drinking some guinnesses this is what
they were drinking in that bar in the
2018 film Arthur wears a bathrobe and
the embroidery looks like the Royal
Hawaiian so Arthur must have stayed at
the Waikiki Resort at some point
actually Jason Momoa slips on this
bathrobe in a completely unhinged Earth
Day Instagram video that he posted last
April go watch it it'll make you like
him a bit yes and make you like saving
the earth a bit less honestly also the
t-shirt that he's wearing underneath
that bathrobe that you can see better in
the laundry day shot with the
clotheslines is my moa's Sabbath Bloody
Sabbath shirt it really just seems like
they let Jason Momoa roll up to set and
whatever he was wearing that day so it
looks like part of Arthur's job is to
save faulting Metro trains in Atlantis
the cars go off the tracks Arthur
catches them and he uses his Trident to
bring them to a stop saving trains is a
classic superhero move even before
Spider-Man 2. as in Richard Donner
Superman Superman used his body to patch
the broken rail apparently the curry
family will not invest in a Drain
Machine as Arthur hangs his green and
orange Aquaman suit to dry I appreciate
how his green gloves are attached to
that scaly orange top I don't know how
he gets this on he must have to go in
hands first Like a Surgeon or a sturgeon
I'm sorry about that let's move on we
returned to the undersea Kingdom of
Atlantis and reminder that there are
Seven Kingdoms unite the seven remember
that wasn't about the Justice League it
was about the kingdoms so the Seven
Kingdoms are Atlantis zebel that's the
kingdom of Mira and her father nerius
the fisherman that's the most
technologically advanced to the kingdoms
they have fish tails instead of legs the
brine that's home of the crustacean-like
people and there are undersea volcanoes
five the trench that's home of the
trench that's a sightless nocturnal
subspecies and the trench is a way to
get to the hidden sea and dead Kings
Island the deserters that's the kingdom
in Ruins that are the Sahara Desert and
seven the lost kingdom of which little
is known and we will explore in the
sequel in this Atlantis Marketplace they
use jelly
on the side which I would think would be
hard to keep underwater like this but
you know what I think we're gonna enjoy
this movie more if we just don't
question the underwater physics and it
looks like we will be revisiting that
Atlantis Coliseum that we saw in the
first film okay yeah yeah Abdul Mateen
the second returns as Black Manta AKA
David Kane last scene in the
post-credits scene of the 2018 film with
Randall Park his conspiracy theorist Dr
Stephen Shin Black Manta has an
Atlantean armored suit and still swears
Vengeance on Aquaman after the death of
his father in their failed piracy
Mission he still Bears his scar across
his face that had been bandaged in that
post-credits scene his submarine looks
like a hammerhead shark as he swears to
kill Arthur he wears a heavy coat that's
covered in snowflakes making me wonder
if he found something in Polar Ice thus
the icebergs we saw at the top of the
trailer presumably the black Trident
that he now Bears which maybe also
something in kalel's Kryptonian fuselage
that's still there in the polar ice
which technically would still be part of
this DC EU continuity later we will see
that black Trident glowing green even
though they call it the black Trident
which makes me wonder if it might be
made of some kind of kryptonite if it's
not Kryptonite maybe it's just the green
color or dark magic that Atlanta refers
to Manta seals himself up in this yellow
submersive cockpit looks like it's part
of the machine that later attacks King
nerius's forces and zebble we actually
see more than one of these skimming
across those icebergs in a later shot
Atlanta comes under attack and then
Arthur and the others find the family
Lighthouse wrecked and on fire but you
know something in the shot whose colors
ain't bleeding the red white and blue
there my friends
really I think the coolest looking shot
in this trailer is later when black
mantis stands triumphant in the coastal
rocks with a collapsing flaming
Lighthouse behind him he did this so are
the curries okay well as the house burns
and the overhead shot we see Arthur
running up followed by Atlanta and then
Marla Hooch Mara and then there's a
fourth person in the back while someone
comes out of the front door hopefully
that's someone as Thomas kind of looks
like he's carrying the baby so I think
they're okay here so Atlanta warns that
Manta Must Be Stopped or a global
meltdown is imminent I'm thinking it's
not just violence I think it's Manta
rapidly rise in global temperatures and
melting those ice caps with more than
just the Warner and DC logo stamped in
the ice now long time new Rockstar's
viewers know how much we use geology and
how long we've been using it for but if
this is your first time hearing about
geology get ready for Blockbuster
quality Skin Care on a student film
budget geology is a 23-time
award-winning skin hair and body care
company recognized in men's health Oprah
daily hypebeast birdie Esquire and DQ
geology's products are just a handful of
powerful proven ingredients that have
been trusted by dermatologists for
decades geology can help you fight acne
reduce oil-ness prevent wrinkles combat
dark or puffy under eyes have smoother
hydrated skin and Target signs of aging
everything you need to keep your skin
healthy no matter how much you soak in
the pool this summer don't know where to
start geology can create a simple and
effective skin care or hair care routine
for you all you've got to do is take a
quick 30 second quiz right now if you
use the code new rockstars 100 geology
will give you 100 off their
award-winning skincare trial set you'll
also get an additional bonus offer of up
to 30 off one skin hair or body products
when you add it to your trial it's truly
a while to offer one of the best they've
ever given our audience so click the
link in the description or go to
geolog.i.e
rockstars100 to get started we return to
the kingdom of the deserters beneath the
Sahara and Arthur uses his blue stealth
suits this blue suit first showed up in
the 1986 Aquaman miniseries designed by
Neil Posner as part of the series that
had Aquaman Amira in Florida that
allowed him to camouflage in the water
James Wan posted that he and David
Leslie Johnson were inspired by that 80s
blue suit and that this is Atlantean
Tech based on a cephalopod's
camouflaging ability while Arthur
appears to us going from invisible to
visible momoa's shadow on the ground is
fully there the whole time so it's not
like the suit can redirect light around
itself to hide the shadow even though
for us to see his body as cloaked and
matching whatever his background is
light would have to be redirected to our
rods and cones because literally
everything we see is light coming into
our eyes bouncing off of that thing
whatever again don't think about the
science like would it also make sense
that the cloaking would apply to
Arthur's face in every strand of Jason
momoa's hair no probably not but it's
okay why is Arthur here well he's
rescuing orm Patrick Wilson who ended
the last film yielding to Arthur in
their duel and agreeing to imprisonment
after learning that their shared mother
Atlanta wasn't actually executed so he
has been imprisoned in that same
deserter Kingdom that Arthur emera
visited in that 20 18 film while Wilson
looks thin and weak initially here in
the next section as soon as he gets into
a bit of water his muscular physique
returns this relationship between half
Brothers is what has me most excited for
this film making it a kind of two-hander
Buddy comedy as they explore the lost
kingdom together kind of looks like a
jungle setting with a volcano spewing
Green Smoke could the color of that
green smoke connect to the green magic
that is coming out of the black Trident
Arthur topples a statue to form a bridge
across the Gap and maybe I'm just
reading into it as I always do
everything but what kind of giant statue
do you position facing away from a giant
Ravine like this like I would just
expect it to either be facing to the
other side or outward with its shoulder
to the pass kind of like the argonath
statues and Lord of the Rings and this
lost kingdom was it seen as a warning to
not cross this divide because of some
thread or dangerous group Beyond this
pass and also at the base of the statue
when Arthur Rams it you can see a door
meaning this isn't just a statue but
it's actually kind of like a building a
structure that you can walk into like
the Statue of Liberty or like a
watchtower or a lighthouse because we
know these Currys love their lighthouses
but also there's an even troller mega
tree beside it so I don't know why you'd
have this Watchtower when you could just
build a lookout perch on top of that
huge tree I don't know maybe the tree
grew after that Tower and that's how
long this place has been lost and so I
would just imagine the time it took for
that mega tree to grow would be the time
it took for that Cliff to start eroding
or that statue just collapsed on its own
due to gravity and all the plants
growing through it I don't know I think
I'm thinking about this way too hard
let's move on okay Arthur and Orem visit
this shark Society two Warriors flanking
them while a third behind them steering
whatever vessel they're on we know India
Moore is playing carshon who in the
comics is a Green Lantern villain tiger
shark a what a tiger shark that quickly
mutated after exposure to nuclear waste
giving him intelligence and telepathy we
get a shot of manta marching toward us
and flipping the black Trident and we
see it as a delayed effect as a lower
bar flips up into the prongs of the
Trident activated so this trident really
comes in two parts we flash back to an
ancient battle showing King atlin's
defeated the previous wielder of the
black Trident at Lin is the first king
of Atlantis played here by Vincent
Reagan also known for roles in Clash of
the Titan in Troy and most recently one
piece it looks like he severs the hand
with that black Trident still in it all
this I've been clearly inspired by the
Lord of the Rings prologue when his seal
dur is over the finger with the
shattered blade of narcel with the One
Ring still on it I mean you gotta
imagine with every new piece of
Mythology that Warner's pumping out
they're still trying to recapture that
magic that they had with the Lord of the
Rings trilogy we see some demonic
creatures that look like they are
controlled by the black Trident and
again maybe I've just watched Lord of
the Rings too recently but they do kind
of remind me of the ghost that the dead
man of dunharrow that Aragorn has to
command to fight and then as Manta
stands before this collapsing Lighthouse
some of his minions include
non-humanoids like on the left you see
an octopus also a giant prawn I'm pretty
sure that is Arthur duels Manta tried
into Trident and then faces this massive
crustacean creature going right into its
jaws then another scene when Arthur is
not in his Aquaman suit he tries to
punch a submarine but then gets blown
back with a Sonic Cannon and gets
trapped beneath the boulder one of these
sequences will take Arthur and Orum to
this polar region with these icebergs I
wonder if this is gonna be the final
battle of the movie manta's yellow
machines come across these icebergs and
here we see Arthur her with the Trident
beneath the icebergs releasing kind of
the Sonic shock wave we literally get
half a second of a close-up of Amber
Heard in this Mira punches a crack in a
submarine window it's kind of like the
trailer won't even show her face without
splintering the glass between her and
the camera Aquaman rides a giant icy
horse I think from these Frosty waves
another really cool looking shot mantis
yellow Mech octopus attacks orm I think
it's one of the better looking DFX shots
in the trailer and I think just because
in general VFX objects seen through
murky water always look just a little
fake and unrefined but surfaces that are
in open air and just wet tend to reflect
light in a way that makes their texture
look more Vivid to the human eye and I
think that to me is the biggest obstacle
both at the 2018 Aquaman had to clear
and this movie will have to clear as
well because these movies sell
themselves on being if nothing else
gorgeous spectacles with Arthurian
legendary mythologies but while the
colors are bright and the kingdoms are
always well conceived from a production
design standpoint if they can't be
executed in a way so that all of these
hits and explosions have weight and
impact and just real world physics to
them it's really hard for air breathing
land mammals like us to connect with the
action like this train crash earlier in
the trailer it just doesn't feel as high
stakes if whatever see people inside
those train cars can just swim out of
the windows and gradually have the Open
Water slow them to a safe stop it's not
like Toby Maguire flipping people being
thrown by Doc Ock through the air
because those people would hit the
pavement and die because we don't have
buoyancy and open air now obviously
gripping sticks can be achieved
underwater Avatar the way of water did a
great job it's like the third highest
grossing movie of all time but James
Cameron spent over a decade designing
not just what the undersea flora and
fauna would look like on Pandora but
inventing new filmmaking technology to
capture it in a compelling way and it
came up with these character beats
showing the Sully family learning how to
expand their lungs so that when
characters went underwater we held our
breaths with them James Cameron spent
his entire career figuring how to do
this and you see that Evolution with him
as a Storyteller in movies like The
Abyss in Titanic he's a master at it
James Wan remains at the end of the day
one of our best horror directors and
visual storytellers but telling stories
underwater it's just a landscape that I
don't know if every filmmaker has fully
appreciated outside of James Cameron now
I don't mean to come down too hard on
this so far looking at this trailer I
have reasons to be hopeful so long as
they don't kill that baby I still think
I can get down with this movie but I
can't promise I will be seeing it
opening day because December 20th in
addition to being when this movie
releases is announcement due date of me
and my wife's baby I'm gonna have my
hands full and I won't be eager to watch
a movie that pulls any like that
let me know in the comments below your
favorite part from this trailer and
please subscribe to all three channels
on the new rockstars Network you can
follow me on all social platforms at
eavos thanks for watching I'll see you
next time bye
[Music]
thank you